для ти хто за раз у дорозі хто і світу
яхта плагінів свої місця
ті хто йдуть чого ити 1 приватного краще
знати ель тесь майже все складно
підриваються страху та відриву сорок дві
трохи оправи ми давно їсти без чи шкода
злізти і сечею може змінив це 1 1 за
паливо че і дорослих і дітей всі ті
емоції закону світ не дуже важливо собі
за лунати Петро їм qt4 чого їси
природі я навіть складно а ви про рідню
червоні актив кіль у дена потоплювані мерзотно
вич у тебе б спить його на роботі видих
всього свого на пружині і це може
виявляти тис а до реакції про реван
відділю дано проживають справлю в витрату
витрата ціни тільки люди сумісної але
частий нажити а з приводу сподіваючись ліскою
горюєш праву трату будинку чи людина
белль про тих тамтешнього за вище вся
проживають у витрату б хотів у своїх
частим і роли і ви є батьком вже
у сльозах віч у тебе циля провини за в ірані
і божі не краще видно в агресії над
їх точу першим на б спк тату робота
зараза вас піччю в безвихідь гавкати і по мені
то це ягоди ти на ще був перший день без
мами калли мама кухар таїти з прямого
юнони з відтяжкою що вич увала в розлуці
з може бути вона відразу мило при клубі
личи волонтерам то всім хто подай руку
ось дошка підлітає ще тебе від давнини на
вічність вапно нажаль до травми проти
болі ось lascana про і байти і на
владний рахунок у у вічка ті кому
зарос подаєте руку хто за раз прайма і
допомогу на кусає ці руку і в цьому
хтось допомагаючи важливі в ти клава тис
опитування бачок на вигорить знову аж пензлем
страждань вчора за навколо ми великим учу
їм встигнувши переживана і шуму мантри
моєму старовину травматизацію саду жував
це навантаження ось lascana махає якщо
ти чого ти називатись cecтpa трохи обмитих
хто досі дуже страшно отрута забезпечуючи я з
тобою яскраво-червоні я немає і тим хто набридає допоміг
поважав його пам'ятає і прорізаєте ми
спер чого йому лежали його та speech трохи а
ми так допомагаємо в люди не а треба йому нею
вид і їхній стан жертви на Петро і ми йому
стан безпорадності то в саду
жалю думаю чистіше wannabe дашечка ми можемо
про інвалюту живота людей на вигляді брат
йти сили я те хун і і так набагато
законну людину повз нього бачать сину
wanna чоловіка хочеш таке своєї ділянок
ловко на свою жити і
безпорадність вона забезпечена що люди на
самому розробити найменшу
як що хтось дати наші до рослий повести
вона видна ми можемо сказати я запашних
чого я я бачу я до вас складно алея на
дозволяю так приводу тисячі наших правил
такі мені більше і страшне і саму і
розум іслам та олайя на дозволяє таке
по виробленню вам важливі повернення б ти c&c
відчутно я можу вам допомогти батькові вам
важливий його за роботою самі спочатку з
Путінці
процес адаптації до нових умов травня свою
динаміку
3 andes укусів схему процесу соціальної
адаптації ще складаєте заспівання це піф
я всі висоти їх просто етапи будуть
називати десяток добра йоржи доки вона
красі і знову добрі-добрі
Томатина бізнес і не ентузіазм душевно
побажав його не було кіно геї наріжте
лікувати а б спп пит ринку то свободи
тут важливі балконом і ти син це ресурси
надходило панова тарного місця
інше серж та почуття дискомфорту
взаємного на розуміння за безцінним та
жителям і то на екрані океан і
культурний шок це може виробляти і door
чарівність то й зауваження щодо зіллються в
обліку автора важливі вас пости регати
занесемо і жителям і ви в чат та провалу
це як традиції мову нама хаттах я
спинку в тис вона найкраща земля до моєї
загальної атака можна звістку про храм де божо
його включать я встиг вижити, а запит у
цій галузі зростання виду допит області
правом то традиції важливим
обумовлюватися a cool thing that і
криється і включать якщо на допомогу пройти
пуху на на чому етапі можна зростання татуха
і значить і сідає віднести ресурсу
може бути раз область дуже важливо і
включення сезо зовнішні процеси будете
влада не діяна на цьому етапі критично
важливо кричати ринку громади ще прайма і
допомога вода птиці та знайомства за
краще не до роботи вашого інвентаризація
владних умінь знай буквально трави
passat ще мають може роботи важливий
питання це проду допоможуть а про панова то
допомогу його немов вата у вічність
чверть краще кухаря тієї тебе трохи а
відданості виявляєте можна вести
слова на 1000 видається оптимізм по
викопаною тобі трохи ж задувало насті вожу
його фіксувати вода будете успіхи і буду вати
плани я ти добрий і на чому етапі ми
підшиваємо всі стейки в контакті є
своїм ресурсам цьому жив його стіни буду
йому та в тілі йому плані на мій бот
культурний шок про фей виявила вище
термін за пропан іван iii марокканським
антропологом чином коли людина
поправляючи в navi розумом та її сенсору не
символічніше в арболіті невербальні
системи не визнають звучні он його ми
каємося з станковий нам вже одразу mytouch
його видно на хочеш втекла що ви на
жити а я як досі контролювати
порибачу етапу вадим queen шах циклу до
відриву хута паніку мети дійти до того часу
поки ми не дійшли джиму особливості
культурний код їм крок людей не знаємо
і все про них не звучки але мабуть у
майбутній контакт тому дуже важливо як
тільки з є син і входу контакт
важливі воді знову тисяча місяців людей
і культуру в чиїсь мові ті кого ти все
історію по вожатими секунди
заглушаючий у can take these своїй
культури цієї ідентичності важливі в куб
це взяті собою 5 тій книзі українській
мови важливі розроблені бирку козаків
пишемо зате ще до по мужності ритий
листок світ усередині шни юта за зовнішню
реальність you do to which у тя упори
таке мені
ще в дорозі цитата про місця України
я до її будинку ось це на екскурсії ти хто
поїхав менше місця і МТС Україна може
пройти на синдром того ще виживши
почуття права назад ще знаходиться в без
приємних умовах вожу його по мені то ти
сів на голці в ніші жити, а шкіра з нас
знаходиться на своєму місці завжди на
своєму у фронті і можете відкласти а
дітей абсолютно цінність та шкіра на думку
про українську слова пит ринку шкірно добре
слово та газу в дикий вашої половинки
вашим раціям вашим ідеям скаже про
україну то українців видних у вічних
засланих 7 ссн їх c високо наш українець і
взагалі сили будуть скоро дуже винний вже
потрібно наближається доба вічка